nos piden encontrar la raíz cúbica de
menos 512 otra manera de ver esto es que
si tengo un número que es la raíz cúbica
de menos 512 esto significa que si elevo
dicho número al cubo obtengo menos 512 y
si no puedes ver inmediatamente cuál es
el número que se eleva al cubo
obtienes menos 512 lo mejor que puedes
hacer es realizar una factorización de
números primos pero antes de que hagamos
esa factorización de números primos y
veamos cuáles son los factores que se
repiten por lo menos tres veces
analicemos cómo considerar este signo
negativo en el número menos 512
reescribamos esto aquí la raíz cúbica de
menos 512 es lo mismo que la raíz cúbica
de menos 1 por 512 y esto esto es igual
a la raíz cúbica la raíz cúbica de menos
1 x
la raíz cúbica la raíz cúbica de 512 y
está aquí tiene una respuesta inmediata
que número al elevarlo al cubo obtenemos
menos 1 esto es menos 1
- 1 veamos menos 1 al cubo es igual a
menos 1 x menos 1 x menos 1 y esto es
igual a menos 1 así es que la raíz
cúbica menos 1 es menos 1 así es que
tenemos menos 1 que multiplica a esto
que tenemos aquí menos 1 por la raíz
cúbica de 512 veamos cuánto nos da esto
hagamos la factorización con números
primos 512 ese entonces 2 por 256 256 2
x 128 128 es 2 por 64 aquí ya tenemos 32
es 64 es 2
32 2 x 32 32 es 2 por 16 muchísimos 2
están saliendo 16 es 2 por 8 8 es 2 por
4 y 4 es 2 por 2 tenemos una gran
cantidad de 12 si multiplicamos 2 por sí
mismo 123456789 veces obtenemos 512 512
ese entonces 2 a la novena y eso ya nos
da la pista de cuánto en la raíz cúbica
512 pero si no podemos hacer grupos de
entonces
aquí tenemos por ejemplo veamos grupos
de 12 aquí tenemos tres grupos de 2 2 es
aquí tenemos un grupo de 22 es aquí
tenemos otro grupo de 22 es y aquí
tenemos otro grupo de 22 es aquí tenemos
entonces que es 4 elevado al cubo pero
mejor aún mejor aún vamos a hacer grupos
de 32 es tenemos aquí entonces un grupo
de 32 es
aquí tenemos entonces otro grupo de 32
es y finalmente aquí tenemos un tercer
grupo de 32 es ahora cada uno de estos
grupos es 2 x 2 x 2
este es 8 aquí también tenemos 2 x 2 x 2
8 y aquí también 2 x 2 x 2 esto es igual
a 8 entonces tenemos que 512 es igual a
8 por 8 por 8
así es que volviendo a nuestra expresión
original raíz cúbica de 512 esto lo
podemos escribir como este menos 1
equivale a poner un signo de menos así
es que esto es menos la raíz cúbica
de 8 x 8 x 8 y la pregunta es nuevamente
qué número si lo multiplicó por sí mismo
tres veces o si lo elevó al cubo obtengo
512 y aquí vemos que es claramente 8 x 8
x 8 claramente entonces esto es 8 así es
que esto de aquí se simplifica como 8 y
la respuesta a la pregunta original
la raíz cúbica de menos 512 es menos
menos 8 y así hemos terminado y puedes
verificar este resultado multiplica por
si mismo menos 8 3 veces vamos a hacerlo
menos 8 x menos 8 x menos 8 menos 8 x
menos 8 es 64 positivo y eso x menos 8
nos da menos 512